こんにちははじめ社長ですねっ高校私では
自ら買ったさおくんのお家なんですけども
まぁだねまだいろいろなが整ってなくて
結局自由な生活してるんですよまずガスが
通ってない実質何だろうなお風呂が入れ
なかったり4階建てだろにエレベーターが
付いてないこれ育ちものの持つ運びが超
大変ということですメットだもんなんか
みんなに抱えて移動とかして欠点って色々
あるんですけどもマットもっと大きな
もっと大きな欠点見つけてしまいました
それは何かそう広すぎてですねわかり
づらいんですよ部屋が大広い別れづらい
正直僕はまだどこどのように使えばいいの
かよくわかってないって今回はそれを張っ
た利益するためにどんなお客さんが来ても
この部屋がこういう変なんだここはこれが
鉄ダメなんだとかここはこれしていいんだ
とそれで1人のみではフェイスように今回
こんなものを寸日しました
レセプションどうですか皆さん見覚えある
のはありませんそうこれサインプレートと
呼ばれるものでどういう時に使うんだと
いうと撮影形成してを製品ほど撮影
キンシャサ員を置いたりおトイレ高本の
部屋が分かれてなかったですよホント
難しいしを打ちえっオシャレすぎてどんな
部屋が旦那の子俺もマジわかんないから
そんな時のためにね道で売買部使える
ブーバーたいと夕食早速3件の合計あー山
ほど社員貼っていきましょうツアー化され
てるからカーっと日だけエアー
マジで監視カメラついてるってホント変な
ことしたらまずで捕まえるんでやめて
ください強化しをちょっとこれ
どうですか
これは姉あつあるねえ
大手ではここに貼ってあるねちょっと外
影響かしたいところである
いうところねごめん朝刊紙があるとついて
いる高校とかどうでしょうか入っとんで
まずパトロールしてもらってるんで大堂々
勝手に駐車されてもやだからこれもどっか
に貼っていきたいなんだ
凡庸もう一問やれや思った
このハット帽かう
どうでしょうね結果へどうぞあれいいです
ねもの投げ込まれちゃたまらんからね
よしよしよしすごいやつよもうここさあ車
の出入りも俺たちするかもしれねえから者
にもあんまりこと人しかないしょっちゅう
行っはこれもうちょっと外張りたよねー
これもしっかりあってイェイ絶対調理ず
名所間違えて入ってるような猫祭りた行か
れたら困るなその後もこれで関西からダメ
だよってなるほどなるほどなるほど
いやここ情報量多すぎでしょこれ大事です
からねやっぱりないですねええいいんじゃ
ないですかけっこうこれだけはどうしても
伝えたい印象ってだけほんとダメなので
あとはざまーす使わせちゃだめですよ
かっこいいよねぇ
ブーバーあるやつあるをなめられちゃを
じゃあねもう一枚どっから入った
ああはって人の車1なければも貼った後
そうですねもう3枚ででちょっと行きたい
のに
正面がこういうことを貼っておきたいよね
まずでものすごい量の監視下においている
からといいならはいっしょみんなすぐ食べ
ちゃうんでねまず捕まえよ alsok
ケーンと一緒に置いておくのが効果的だと
思う
そうでしょう
あつありますよ
俺ん家で確認義務はでいた家なきゃ一番
でかいですよさあだいぶ英国系わかった気
がしますね当たっちゃいます中谷当直水で
とか屑入れ
楽にああやったねー健介の車ですよ俺の頃
はで送るな時代が駐車ぞっていうその概念
を壊す買ったなるほどねみんな変化も駐車
場がよくっそおそお以降月1票朱雀んだっ
たに行きましょうか
[音楽]
警戒させたように
色だろっ
[音楽]
あーこれいや同じで壊れたんだけど所なん
ですよ
走行に混ぜたんですかね
こいつがタワー
そのターン
pa
圏論で明治売ってる倉橋でおねえ
官兵衛のしかも前を開けても大丈夫です
のかを学習した方の俺どうじゃ
明日沿いの花線される残りハムがここが真
のクズいでですねんかもう掃除めんど
くさいんでなんでも入れ t 業者にお
願いして海をまとめせてるから俺はまつげ
なくくず入れでしょうねわかりやすくね
これはゴミなんでも返して
いれば大丈夫ですか隠れ組はお断りしたい
んです圭佑とかが何か良い家の後に持って
くるとちょっとやだからなぁめんどくさい
となってアケビは断りませんだけど大事
です痛いちょっとこういうさあ部屋に根を
張ったよくん
ここなになっているかというか倉庫みたい
なと言うとこうやってここは勝って下がっ
たし言ってほしくないからおやつはこれが
ありましょうかどうでしょ
a 俺めっちゃぽくなってきたらよしでは
仲いいましょういやーとこう
基本的に家キーなんですけど玄関なら
大きいみたいな考え
ta です
悲しいちょっとこういう怪談ライブでさせ
ていただきますら辺かなという
なんか何だったここと入れないよ
わかりづらく確かパッと見なければただの
さあドア4これだけバジャー早いですね
通り音分かるようにしれないねはいはい
福寿司か入れない所わかりやすいジャック
パーセル盛り上げてみませんか
首でした水葉藤田悠
くっついるになる予定の場所でスタッフの
方でし小機構大きな声が方もね今ともここ
が with な wi-fi ベアなの
でいうか1 by チャリで行ってどう
ですかわかりですよイェーイ禁煙ですああ
うってて裸足でまた行きましょう
はぞこういうところで正午のすぎるかなぁ
けどぱすぽねーぞくるんで
用例所
吐き出される応援すんだとアイエフな
ついたよねこっちに2つあるのはこの遅い
出やすい興津覚えるなこれコーチは抗議書
冊数がにわかりやすい
ピップ連れ込まれると困るんでね
同伴可ということケース客を使っちゃいけ
ないあーなるほどっ
キッチンとトリュフいるじゃ今のターン
客観規制で前期んじゃなくってああかぼす
目えー
絶対ないですから絶対だ君が歓喜神の
悲しい声を聞こえたと思いまーさーああ
グルーができてきたよほの家の瓶カーもう
だめよの下よ
ところですよねー5便ばこれ外付け砂糖
[音楽]
はっはっは猫背すぎるだろ俺
男は背中で方のレース用しね買ったとき
から割と所々変わってる場所があるので
ここから結構変化があると思います
ないように誰だけどタバコ臭ではこここゆ
たんとうちに食べていけるあれでも私だけ
頼んだませんお祝い葛藤してくれエコから
なんですけど僕が土足人気になるんですよ
ちゃんと殺人夢って言うんですって
たいことがあるどうでしょうですね俺の
ながらちょっとルールがあってい12回は
もう事務所的な扱い p 主とかともが
する
34回は結構奥津も脱ぐしプライベート
空間にしようという考えでございます3階
のことにはもうほぼね俺の部屋っぽくなっ
ている飲酒を禁止します
絶対無理でしょこの部屋では絶対飲食禁止
です
[音楽]
none
う
をもさあスリップした星に来ると頭から
入ったらぜってーし
気をつけてますねここはちょっ
なんかさ
種類が違うねいやーですねその間危険とか
で倒せるぞ編みですね
しっかり品とさせていただきますだけでは
みんな食べてここが弾み社長完全
プライベート部分なんですけど茶聖に
プライベートルーム4回まちと昆布の
プレートにはネタ白こっからと北京したし
ておりますここからはホット宣言しという
ことで背中なんですけども不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不来ベイト空間
音を言いてちゃっていいかオーナーもう
メインチャンネルのとか塗料俺人入れと
どこトレなっちゃうから
ここで完全ボーヌ1いっよくやってい
q する農民輝するかな ok 4階は
これでい気がします
はい時でかなり3型の家サインプレート
たくさん初なのでを分かりやすくなったの
かなと思います9しっかり強化されたり猫
の家全体が目とってももうサインプレート
で溢れかえってしまいました応用よ
ちょっとまあ具合をも誰が来ても生きて
トイレが毒がとかああああ入っちゃダメだ
と説いたばする a というふうに初めて
家に来る人ばサップってぜひ張りすぎだ
よってくださいいやーすごい
あっ
[音楽]
はあっ
は